thank you all so much for being here i'm
just so surprised that there's anybody
here on a thursday night
i don't know how i got on a program with
uh irv grossbeck and dean joss and jim
van horn and all the other luminaries
they're on this and i agonized a little
bit over you know what should i
do what should i say to just kind of you
know impart anything that would be worth
you spending an hour of your time and as
i started thinking about i thought you
know great athletes visualize what
success would be and so i started to
think about you know what would it
really feel like and you know to do a
good job and i and i remembered a story
by about
judge learned hand who's probably the
greatest american jurist who never was
appointed to the u.s supreme court and
one day they asked judge hand
what a perfect day
would be like for him and he said well
i'd wake up late i'd have breakfast in
bed i'd be carried into the stadium to
cheers of
my arrival
after the festivities
i would
go and have a leisurely bath and then
that evening be driven to an elegant
dinner party where would be assembled
all of the great minds of all time
and part of the way through the dinner
party the
crowning moment would come when somebody
would stand up and say shut up voltaire
we want to listen to learn at hand
and so my version of this is tonight
you'll say we want to we want to stay
late on thursday night and listen to
joel peterson
this idea of a last lecture um i as i
understand it came up in around the
1960s and was pioneered at brandeis
university and the idea there was that
they would ask people to come and give a
talk as it were the last opportunity
they would ever have to speak to a group
of students
i was so inspired by this idea that i
started one of these last lecture series
at my alma mater and i found that our
the people that we uh invited
would do one of two things they would
either do like uh jim van horn just did
and speak about something where they had
world-class knowledge i recall inviting
dr henry eyring who is a world-class
chemist
and he spoke about the dancing molecules
and they came
alive
and that was it was really interesting
to see people with a passion for their
area of expertise and then others
really were more literal they just said
what if you really were never going to
talk to these people again what would
you want to tell them what would you
want them to know
and
so that's kind of what i've decided to
do tonight is really be literal about
this what would i tell you if this were
the last chance
one of the students asked me tonight
before i came in here well are you going
to talk about real estate or private
equity investing and i'm not going to
talk about either uh one of those
in order to get you to pay attention to
what i'm going to say because you may
laugh when i finally get to the the
topic after this long
labored introduction
i need to tell you my qualifications
um
the first one is luck
uh and i think
mba students would probably understand
that best in terms of having made money
one more time that i've lost it
um
and
i hasten to add that we're only in the
seventh inning there and i've got
partners that
would say there's still plenty of time
left for you to blow it again and you
have proven capacity
the second thing is experience i've made
a lot of mistakes um
i've been on a number of boards uh
dozens of boards actually over the years
done a handful of startups
built projects all over the world have
borrowed billions of dollars and made
the mistake of personally guaranteeing
it
and then spent millions of dollars uh
trying to
uh
recover a fragment of what those
billions of dollars had built
and probably the most relevant
experience i've had is that i've i'm the
father of seven uh kids
and that's probably the most
managerially qualifying part of my whole
experience and the final is a certain
amount of cunning and i'll offer is uh
proof of that cunning only one reference
point and that is that i've been able to
convince my wife of 30 years to stick
with me proving
what abra half of what abraham lincoln
said about you can fool
some of the people all of the time
so what you'll have other people here
that will demonstrate by the way these
are my two daughters coming in here and
uh
before i started tonight i thought they
would be the only friendly faces
here
but i recognize a number of uh students
from class here so i'm actually more
comfortable when i thought i'd be so
other other people
rely on intellect
speaking prowess
profound knowledge of a subject matter
i'm going to be relying on luck
battle scars some ugly experiences
and
limited street smarts
what i'm going to offer you tonight is a
a map a fragment of a map
and it's a fragment of a map that's
unique to territory i've traversed it
doesn't have much to do
really with what you'll be doing but i
think it'll prove valuable to you and
let me tell you why
a few years ago i was climbing mount
kilimanjaro with a small party and we
were nervous about whether or not we
were going to be able to make it to the
summit
and we were talking about it we knew it
was high and we'd had some good friends
who'd been uh triathletes who'd run in
the iron man who had not made it to the
summit and so we were talking about it
when we ran into a couple of elderly
british women coming in they were in
their late 60s early 70s and they told
us about taking diamox and how to
acclimate
and where to purify your water and how
to climb volcanic scree and just all
kinds of really helpful things but the
thing that was really helpful was the
visual image of these
70 year old women who had made it to the
top and we looked at each other and said
we can do this
you know we're younger we're in better
shape we've got better equipment
in the same way
i'm telling by seeing me up here you
know
that you will have no trouble making it
up the hill i'm younger than that guy
i'm better looking than that guy i'm in
better shape i got better training so
this this map is going to have some
value to
you now as i started to sift through the
detritus of the 55 years i've been
around trying to do stuff
the most valuable thing
to me was to talk to you about finding
happiness in life and i recall when i
was in school about your age i was
thinking you know really it's making
money
it's getting power
it's
fame or celebrity it's having influence
it's gathering about me all those things
that will measure my success
uh i've since come to the point of uh
and i'll put a slide up here because
i've referenced it
um
by using a quote from a fellow by the
name of frederick beaconer who says that
human happiness
is a function
of
finding discovering the person you are
to be
someone to love and a work to do
and so i'm going to organize my thoughts
on happiness
kind of around
around that quote
let me make one comment about happiness
before i jump into this by the way
most of what i'm going to talk about
tonight because this is the stanford
business school will have to do with the
work you have to do but it really
wouldn't be fair of me not to make a
couple of comments about the first two
this is like a three-legged stool
in the end and if you only get two out
of the three right you will not find
ultimate contentment uh in your life in
my experience so let me now make a uh
a brief comment about
this kind of continuum of well-being
you can decide where you want to be on
this continuum i think this talk will be
more or less relevant wherever you
decide
you'd like it to be
other than maybe the pleasure end of it
which infants
get by getting a bottle and you get my
just sort of immediate physical pleasure
if you if you were the kinds of people
for whom that were the most important
thing we would not be sitting here
in the bishop auditorium tonight you
would be in las vegas or something else
so i'm not too concerned about that but
that's i think that's the first
the first comment now let's start
talking a little bit about uh each of
these
first let me say something about
discovering uh the person
you are to be and give a couple of
thoughts on sort of practical ways you
might go about that it was gerta who
said that if you want to be somebody you
have to or if you want to
accomplish something you must first be
something
so it really starts out with um
with being somebody there are four ways
that i'd like to suggest that you think
about
discovering self-discovery the first way
is a pretty obvious one that is to read
and i don't mean
business cases although tomorrow morning
i would appreciate it if my
s 355 class would read their business
case
or finance journals or things like that
i mean read broadly read biographies
read about other countries read books by
people with completely different
perspectives
from your own read
uh read things by people who disagree
fundamentally with you
if you read a book a year
and then do the real estate calculation
on how much that binding would cover
you'll find that at the end of your life
you'll really only be able to to cover
the walls of about a 10 by 10 foot cell
so it's a pretty small little abode that
you're papering with whatever you decide
to read
you will in a significant degree become
what you think about in life and you
will
think about what you read
don't limit the person you are to be
by
reading only newspapers
only magazines only professional
journals
read broadly
the second thing that i would suggest
you consider is memorizing stuff
that means something to you i remember
reading about
the pows who survived in vietnam and the
ones who did the best were ones who had
something that they could recall and
think about
and if you do decide to commit things to
memory pay attention to what it is you
decide to commit if i take off the top
of my stack you'd hear things like out
of the pit out of the night that covers
me black is a pit from pole to pole i
think whatever gods may be for my
unconquerable soul
sweeter the uses of adversity when it's
darkest men see the stars
the stronger the wind the stronger the
tree
um yea though i walk through the valley
of the shadow of death i will fear no
evil well what does that tell you about
me what does it tell me about me you
know is that i've had to really think
about this whole issue of adversity and
overcoming odds and things like that as
i thought about i said where does this
come from
and i remember when i was 10 years old
playing in a little league baseball game
and being assigned to right field
while the pitcher walked in
24 runs and i was out there for a couple
of hours
not a ball ever
well i went uh back home to my dad and
said i'm quitting i do not want any more
of this and he said petersons never quit
and that thing somehow got cranked into
my dna at an early age and i i've been
suffering from it ever since and i was
telling my group the other day that i'm
like uh the black knight in the monty
python skit who has his arms and legs
cut off says it's only a flesh wound
but pay a lot of attention to what it is
you choose to memorize because you'll
get an insight into who you are
the third thing i would suggest is write
out a mission statement
you would not
finance a business without a business
statement nor would you start a business
without creating a business statement
and yet most of you are willing to go
through life without thinking through a
statement of philosophy values goals etc
i'm not going to bore you with the
details but my wife and i 30 years ago
put together a family philosophy and
from this
we developed a regimen that all of our
kids had which ended up in them learning
languages learning to play instruments
going on survival
camps i mean a lot of misery
we found out a whole lot about who we
were what our values were it was really
very self-revealing for us to go through
this
and um
of course our kids are messes now but we
know each other and know our values
a year ago we gave copies of this family
philosophy
to our married kids and i'll bet you
anything that there's
a whole new generation that will be
tormented
by this
the final advice i would have for you in
discovering who you are to be and i
don't want this to appear morbid but go
to a funeral every year
and pay attention to what they say about
the deceased what is valued in their
life and then think and if you if you
want to write your own obituary i've
done this a couple of times
and
once you get over the idea of it it's
amazing to realize what you have not
become that you would really like to be
said about yourself it forces you to
think about your legacy and what's
important
and so i think if you'll do uh
those things which are uh to read
attempt to write out a life plan
memorize and pay attention to what
you've done and then reflect on the
legacy you leave you'll approach what
socrates had engraved
above the door at the temple of delphi
which was no thyself
having thoughtfully considered that
ancient admonition you'll have
begun to attach the first leg of this
stool now the second one and i won't
dwell on this one
too much either because it's
uncomfortable a lot of times for people
in business schools to talk about things
like love but think in terms of words
like
approbation
approval validation you know whatever
words make you feel comfortable
the first the first way to develop this
uh this second leg of the tripod that
will support your happiness in the long
term in life
is to realize that love is a function of
sacrifice
in general
we we light we love what we pay a big
price for
i've often wondered if that isn't the
reason behind the tuition here at the
gsb
you know as second years
you know or or even at the end of your
first year you're really uh
should be feeling the love
by now
i had a good friend in college who
claimed that he had always wanted a son
and he was just so excited uh when his
son was uh
born and he was surprised that he not
only didn't feel a real love and a real
bond with this child but he actually
kind of resented that his wife was so
distracted and that his sleep was
interrupted that was really his his take
on this whole thing
and
then his wife got sick
and she was sick for quite a while and
pretty seriously ill so it became his
job to deal with the midnight feedings
the messy diapers and the unrelenting
demands of a helpless little boy
and by magic as he reports it over time
he found this bond developing
based on this sacrifice that was made it
has grown and developed of course into
an unbreakable and lifelong connection
the lesson in this is sacrifice for that
which you would love
the second one is make a commitment
who's does to somebody who doesn't
deserve it um recently my wife and i
began working with a violent convicted
felon to whom we were assigned and some
volunteer work that we're doing um and
we have come to really and genuinely
care about this fellow and it's really
not because he's so lovable um
it's really because we were assigned and
we made a commitment and we just kept
doing it
now i know this flies in the face of
everything we're taught in business
school about maximizing returns on time
and money
but i am really confident at least in
this last lecture series that where i
never to talk to you again i would say
that there is some perverse economy of
spirit
that makes it so that those who give
benefit more than the intended
beneficiaries so make some irrational
gifts
uh to people of time and energy and care
now before i give an unqualified
recommendation to this particular
strategy
i have to ask if any of you have seen
this play a thousand clowns anybody
aware of that oh good i'm so glad you
need to see this
isn't it fabulous they used to play it
every year at harvard at exam time and
everybody would take exam we can go see
a thousand clowns again it's this
irreverent 1950s
play about the world of work
start the movie stars jason robards and
martin balsam and she'll be in that
event there's a young
social worker named sandy in the film
who says that
you know she
was starting to work with this young boy
named raymond ledbetter and she didn't
like raymond ledbetter because she
didn't understand him
then she spent some time with raymond
ledbetter
and after three weeks of time with len
raymond ledbetter she understood him
and now
she hated him
the world is full of raymond ledbetters
and you may run into them and they may
be testing
you more likely than not they don't feel
they deserve to be loved
my advice would be when you can
occasionally care about them anyway i'll
bet you if you think back on your own
life you'll realize that there's been
somebody who has had an irrational care
for you
and so it's it's something that will
allow you to develop
this ability to love which is the second
part of building this stable stool
the final one the final
approach to that is don't allow
grudges and bitterness anger desire for
retribution
to reside in you and i i have to tell
you a uh a personal story here because
it's really the the way i have
probably learned this the best um i
spent several years in litigation and it
was brutal eviscerating uh litigation i
spent 14 days in videotape deposition
dozens of hearings millions of dollars
with lawyers i mean it was it was really
miserable
and i walked into the courtroom
to face my accusers and the first time i
saw them i mean the testosterone was
pumping
and um
and i i think i
i really despised these people for what
they had
had done and my wife perceived this
alarming level of animus and she reached
over and grabbed me by the arm and said
think about the good times that we had
with these people
reflect on the wonderful things they did
for us and then this was the killer said
now now show them that we love them
well i mean
how would you respond i i was just
you know it just seemed like such utter
nonsense to me
and i really wanted to lash out at her
to begin with
and that but i really want to just
instruct her han how justified my fury
really was
today though i really see wisdom in that
because i know that had i allowed my
bitterness to fester and
joint venture with
their anger and the things that they had
done i would today be a far lesser
person
so if you would know love in your life
you must also
not give reference yet refuge to
bitterness
okay
now i'm going to move us to
this fourth um or this third area which
is the work to do and really focus on
that because that's what you're here for
and i'll see if i can
pull this off
so being we've talked about being we've
talked about loving
and now working
um
the key
the final key to finding happiness is
finding a work that you feel passion for
and that you can do effectively and
efficiently
i'm going to focus tonight on the work
of leaders because that's why you've
come
to business school
it's what it's preparing you to be
overarching your eventual success as a
leader is an attitude that you must have
and um
i think you need to be grateful for the
opportunity to be a leader a lot of
people seek leadership for the wrong
reasons and there are a lot of people
who do it poorly because of that
i was fortunate to work with a guy for
20 years who is a terrific person who
used to say virtually every week if not
every day work is more fun than fun
and that kind of an attitude brought to
leadership is infectious and it will
really change so start with that
now let's talk specifics
in my experience there are four things
that leaders have to do and do well to
be successful
they have to do with pathfinding
team building communicating and being a
person that others can trust those are
really the four categories and i know
people all kinds of people talk about
leadership and they group the activities
different ways
but i'm going to talk just very briefly
about being a pathfinder and a team
builder and then really spend some time
on these last two which i think are the
most difficult the most critical and the
most likely to let you find
uh real meaning in your work and
therefore happiness in your life
path finding
to be a pathfinder or to be an effective
leader you have to
define a definition and to find mild
posts along the way
the one mistake that i think
young leaders make is to confuse the
path with the goal
they work so hard at creating the path
that they become committed to the path
and if you'll actually stay focused on
your values and on your objectives and
share those with the team that you've
got they'll help you rewrite the path
they'll redraw it for you and you'll
have a lot of help in that
the second one on being a team builder
it includes of course hiring promoting
rewarding structuring compensation and
yes firing
some advice here
first of all hire for brains and heart
a lot of people hire for experience and
there are times when that's important
but
my experience is
you can give people responsibility with
responsibility they will get experience
and if they have brains and heart they
will turn that experience into wisdom
which is after all the ability to
predict outcomes and influence outcomes
uh in a proper way
so um
and you're not going to have very much
ability to influence raw intelligence
and their character was probably formed
at their mother's knee you're not going
to have much opportunity to do much
there
so
that's how i would counsel you to hire
if you would be an effective leader
if you're going to terminate and you
will need to terminate people
my advice is to do it sooner rather than
later do it quickly do it humanely
people rarely get better at stuff
and i hate to say that because i just i
want the others so much
you really want to help them get there
but my experience is there's a big
market out there there are a lot of
opportunities and your job is to help
people find their highest and best use
to use a real estate term
when you give feedback to people that
were on your team remember the four to
one rule and that is that if people
receive negative feedback it will take
four
four positive poor pieces of positive
feedback for them to consider it even
somehow we just register not we're just
all sensitive and we just really
register the negative feedback
more than the positive so remember that
one
there really are very few things that
you'll do that will leverage you more if
you learn how to hire right
reward right terminate properly and give
proper feedback you will find your
ability as a leader will be leveraged
many fold okay now let's get into the
two that i want to spend most of the the
time on which are being an effective
communicator
and being trustworthy
these are really tough now on being an
effective communicator first of all
you're all experts in it you've been
communicating since
you were born
we all speak and write and chat and
listen and walk around and we
communicate all day long every day
within teams that we work and externally
to the market so we're experts at that
you couldn't stop communicating if you
wanted to
um but there are five ways that you
communicate and you can become
dramatically more effective as a leader
in each of these five ways we'll touch
on those in just one second
secondly your ability to be trusted
depends on three things and that those
are having character being competent and
being empowered
um to carry through on what you promise
trust is built it's like a building is
built on a on a foundation and that
foundation is rooted in bedrock
trust is the bedrock in which the
foundation built you've got to be rooted
in trust it is
very hard to build
it is easy to destroy
and it's almost impossible to repair
so this issue of trust and being a
leader and engendering trust is a really
big one
and while you communicate all day long
you may not be as expert in the
development and maintaining of trust as
you are in communicating
um
okay let's talk about communicating
first of all i think there are two
things in community the first one is
have something to say
you know there should be substance in
your analysis meaning in your message
recognition of the implications of words
and actions in other words make sure the
beef is there
and then prepare you know do you
remember henry kissinger used to get up
in front of the press corps at his press
conferences and say
do you have any uh questions for my
answers
he prepared you know
he had something to say and he knew what
it was most of you are really
pretty good at this and all of you will
get better with experience
the second part though is communicating
it effectively and here's where the five
ways you communicate comes
in
writing speaking listening behaving and
this specialized form of communication
which we call negotiation
first of all writing
offer some suggestions here write
short memos
use short words
use short sentences think of the
economist which is one of the best read
best written periodicals which deals
with very complex and difficult subject
the average sentence in the economist is
16 words
get to the point
recognize that most people do not like
to read
start with your conclusion support it
with a couple
of examples or your or two or three or
four
of your analyses your arguments people
can't remember much more than that
shakespeare said brevity is the soul of
wit don't forget that
think about the pythagorean theorem is
24 words archimedes principle 67 words
lincoln's gettysburg address 289 words
the 10 commandments are 179 even the u.s
declaration of independence is only 1300
words
it's the really important stuff like the
alternative minimum texts that require
really long
paragraphs and really big words
so learn to
write in a compressed efficient way
secondly speaking
now most of what you say will be
informal
and casual interactions and you're good
at those uh when it comes to formal
presentations though
a couple suggestions i would say get
some training
take a course
in public speaking
take a course in dealing with the press
there's a specialized way of
communicating there and then take a
course in making effective presentations
then
film yourself
listen to yourself on tape
look at your posture pay attention to
all these data points that are really
painful i was sitting in a board meeting
a week or so in
actually a little longer ago than that
in new york it was overcast it was
boring
um you could see the reflections of the
members of the board in the in the
window and so i spent my time rather
than listening to what was going on in
this meeting looking at who all the
board members were until finally i came
to one i said i wonder who that guy is
and i leaned forward and he did too and
i backed up but he did too
i did not recognize seriously i had no
clue i was that old
i mean you do see your i promise you i
see myself as your peer
so get help on that i promise you
listening i won't spend a lot of time on
this a lot has been written and said
about listening but there is this thing
called capturing and listening where you
re and you do reflective listening where
you really don't try to make a point my
wife and i've gone through this a number
of times and talk about a painful
experience you can't say anything for 15
minutes your job is to capture
speak seek out others views look for
negative feedback reward it
be happy to and spend
20 percent of your time listening now
that doesn't necessarily need to be with
your team but with customers or what
really spend a chunk of your time as a
leader listening getting input and that
takes a lot of discipline to do that
okay this fourth one now is this
specialized form of communicating called
negotiation it has its own set of rules
and it it often has to do with
bargaining and offers and counter offers
which can either be formal or informal
written
or
or verbal
in negotiating my advice is to develop a
style
you will very rarely be able to change
your style mid-stream in a negotiation
and i would say to you it even goes
further than that it's hard to change it
mid-career
you get a reputation
for how you deal with people in this
conversation
and some people get a very hard ball
reputation and they really are not
allowed to abandon it so like the style
that you go into your negotiations with
and by the way you negotiate with your
wife and your children and your boss and
your co-workers you're negotiating all
the time it just depends on the level of
formality
let me suggest one way and this is only
one style and it's
and it doesn't always work and it's not
necessarily better than other styles but
i think a reasonable style to consider
is to think about helping the other
party achieve their objectives where
your role is to set a price
on what it takes to get where they want
to go so all you are is
somebody who's making a market in their
objectives and you're really helping
them uh to do that it's a more it's a
more pleasant way
to do that and you won't it but by the
way i would not have ended up in
litigation had i not adopted that style
early on people thought this is a tough
guy he'll he's not going to fight us
whereas i really had to change that
style and go through many years
with trying to establish a new style for
a particular event i would say also and
i know you do that here but read getting
to yes and getting past no those are two
really pretty good books that will give
you a framework that get feedback after
every negotiation the best negotiators
i've worked with used to huddle with the
team afterwards and say how did we do
how could we have done better
you know seek that feedback and refine
your negotiations
wherever possible use negotiations to
build relationships not just do
transactions
and finally never bluff
i know that's potentially controversial
but that would be my it's my last
lecture what the heck
okay the last way can we communicate is
how we behave
um
and it's of course our most potent form
of communication and here my advice
really may surprise you
um
don't say or write out values that
you're unwilling to live
dial down the rhetoric
to whatever you're willing to live by
otherwise what you're going to do is
generate a cynicism around you that you
won't fully appreciate perceive maybe or
understand
and
you may never overcome it
so make sure that you're you're behaving
consistently with what you're saying in
an organization
okay
the good news about all this
communicating stuff is that we can all
get a lot better at it you can practice
it and it's it's something that you can
really work at and become
proficient at
the last point that i want to talk about
is this one of trust building
this one's tougher
and it is the most critical attribute a
leader has
think about it if people can't trust you
they really won't follow you to a
destination that's other than the one
they're going to anyway
now there are leaders out there and i
actually worked with one for a number of
years who said that his idea of
leadership was finding a parade and
getting in front of it
well that's one definition of it if you
really want to make a difference though
let me suggest a handful of ideas
and i'm
going to put up this
last slide here
we're now talking about being trusted
and they're really sort of three areas
one is how you deal with others
the second
is the process and there are two
main processes that will really build
trust and then the third are sort of
personal characteristics that you can
make sure you have that will
dramatically increase how people feel
about trusting you
okay the first one and a lot of these
i'm going to draw in my own personal
experiences
some
family oriented and some business
oriented so i apologize at the outset
for that the first one though in dealing
with others i think these two things are
trust
other people
even when it costs
you
allow them to make some mistakes and you
need to figure out which ones you're
going to allow them to make
but you have to allow people to make
some mistakes and i learned this
personally when i was about 15 years old
i wanted to practice driving our car
up and down the driveway asked my dad
for the keys he tossed me the keys and i
took off and i ended up running it off
into the ditch getting it stuck
i went back in sheepishly and handed him
the keys he came out helped me get it
out of the ditch and then i thought he
would take the keys and that would be
that he tossed me the keys again said
you might want to stay on the driveway
this time
and that that has so inspired me
throughout my life that he was willing
to trust me again after i just blew it
and so when my oldest daughter told me
that she wanted to go to a dance with a
boy prior to the age that we had set up
in our family plan
i said well
you know kind of how we feel about this
and you know all the reasons for it i'm
sure you agree with them and everything
but i trust you to make the right
decision
and why don't you think about it then
come back and tell me about it so she
went off and thought about it i said
rebecca what uh what did you decide
i'm going to the dance
so i had to live with that
i had to live with that and so you have
to decide you know which ones to do it
will
the cost of overriding that decision are
very high on the trust building if you
want to build trust you've got to pick
those moments where you're going to
support people's mistakes
the second one in dealing with others
that i think has more mileage than any
other is to be everyone's assistant in
other words see yourself as
serving other people in the organization
as subordinate to every need anything
that needs to be done in the
organization you're there to help happen
there's a book that i read a long long
time ago by robert greenleaf called
servant leadership that i would
recommend to any of you who are
interested in sort of developing this
idea it turned out to be a a career
changer for me
i started out my career in france and
over there nobody i look at sabine there
none of the office help wanted to learn
how to run the telex machine it was
beneath them
and it was certainly beneath all the
mbas and
and the managers to run the telex
machine so i got out the manuals and
read them in french
learned how to run the telex machine and
that the secretaries would rely on me to
send and receive telex's and i was i
really was happy to do that well one of
the things that happened in doing that
was i saw every incoming and every
outgoing piece of information i got
really smart about what was happening in
the office and i was able to really do
some very good work very early on
in my career the more important message
though is i really developed a trust
relationship up and down that
organization so if you can figure out a
way not to be hierarchical in your
thinking but to be the servant of all
you'll read in this book if you read any
of it about
herman hess's journey to the east where
he describes leo
the servant who helps them who's the
sherpa or whatever it's a mythical
journey but he's the one who helps the
party get to the summit as it were when
leo is gone they don't make it all these
leaders all these muckety mocks don't
make it without the servant and that's
the metaphor
so i think those two things trusting
others allow you to make mistakes and
then figuring out where there's a need
serving that need and not being worried
about hierarchy okay the second thing
then has to do with process
management
there are two
main times two points of pain
when you can really increase
the trust that you have with your
organization and that is managing in
times of change
and managing in times of adversity and
let me make some comments about each of
those
because i promise you you will deal with
both of these
on change
people don't like change and almost any
organization that you go to work for
or organize will suffer from change
fatigue
as george will says most improvements
make things worse
when you make a change
and you will make sure you're moving
toward a goal and not away from
something that you
don't like
in other words figure out what it is you
want to achieve and move then don't just
move because you want to get away
from something make changes sooner than
later i remember one time
being excited to build a uh a home and
showing the plans to one of my partners
who had built secondary
recreational houses and he looked at it
and i was ready to to sign the contract
and get going with the architect and i
really wanted to get going i didn't want
to change anything in the plans he
looked at them and he said
if you build this this way
these ceilings will always be at eight
feet
well that's so obvious
but if you think about it the ceilings
will always be at eight feet there's
some things that if you intervene early
you can with a with with a sleight of
pencil
you can change those ceilings from eight
to nine to ten feet if you do it early
if you do it late they will always be at
eight feet so make your changes sooner
rather than later when you're making
changes
assume that everyone is smart
people even the dullest people you work
with are pretty smart when it comes to
organizational change so assume people
are smart and assume they're volunteers
people have options
all employment is at will employment
virtually
and just assume that they're volunteer
that they're smart volunteers so you
need to bring them along
uh when you present a change for
execution keep it simple any of you have
had classes from me have heard me quote
my favorite
supreme court justice oliver wendell
holmes who said i would not give a fig
for the simplicity this site of
complexity but i would give my life for
the simplicity the other side of
complexity problems are complex issues
are complex if you stop short of dealing
with the complexity you'll have simple
mind you'll be making simple-minded
changes that won't work
if you try to
execute at the complex stage you'll fail
you've got to get to the other side of
complexity to that simplicity in order
to be successful
then
i've mentioned this to one of my classes
think through the implications of your
change in the screens i run that through
or first of all what would my lawyer say
is it legal second would i like it to
appear on the front page of the wall
street journal
third
uh what would i feel like if my neighbor
did that to me and the fourth is the mom
test
could you tell your mom about it
um
always do what is right
this will gratify some people and
astonish the rest said mark twain
finally when you make a change that
doesn't work
admit it take the blame and move on okay
now dealing with adversity which is the
other point of of real uh trust building
opportunity
when the chips are down you really will
build trust and i'm going to give you a
couple of
the most important thing to say here
from my experience is to prepare for
adversity you will face it i don't know
when in your life i thought i would
never see it and then
it all hit and when you're in a fire
fight
you don't know how you'll react
you don't know when you're overrun
where the bullets will be coming from
and you really don't know so prepare for
it and let me give you several uh
suggestions on preparing for adversity
the first one
is that to expect to feel bad
you're going to feel a certain level of
panic or depression
uh when things when bad things happen
especially you all
you are batting
close to a thousand in your lives i mean
you really have had this unbroken string
of successes and you don't really know
what this feels like so you're going to
feel maybe more panic than some people
who run into a few more brick walls
you'll be less tempted to give in to any
ill wind that blows if you expect
that the the feeling of
depression or panic
knowing that you'll get a second wind
and you have to know this just like any
of you who are runners
it actually happens you do get a second
win you will get a second win and that
will allow you to survive the initial
waves of exhaustion panic despair
whatever
and to then succumb to the worst that's
in you
the
having the equanimity
to know that this two will pass
is a really powerful thing to develop i
want you each to take one second and
think about the most embarrassing thing
that has ever happened in your life
you've all at least had those
well see i don't see any red faces
i don't see anybody crying getting up to
leave the room
you know that passed
all these things pass and so if you know
that that is a really powerful place to
start with dealing with adversity
secondly is don't waste any
time or energy on blame when things go
wrong as analytical people
you have a proclivity to go in and
figure out what went wrong
because you're good at that
when you're good with a hammer you think
everything is a nail
so you're that's mark twain too so you
want to uh
you really don't want to spend time and
energy
adversities wounds can be self-inflicted
other inflicted environmentally
inflicted
others can do us harm bad stuff happens
routinely life isn't fair
any time you spend on that will take
away from time you could spend on what
you do to deal with adversity
i'm going to skip this next one in the
in
the interest of time
and
i'll just mention this one is to
stockpile good memories
uh that you will draw down on i won't
give you examples
um generate a specific backup plan and i
would say you know deal with issues like
finances healthcare education child care
create a safe harbor in other words for
yourself a safe place to go
in anticipation of of that and taking
care of your health your relationships
and work while that's hard to do
it's a lot easier to maintain it than it
is to rebuild it when it's gone so make
sure those are solid
and then finally the last thing i think
i would say is do not fear conflict
in times of adversity there will be
conflict you have to know that that's a
big part of adversity
embrace it
as odd as that seems people around you
need you to be a warrior they need you
to be undaunted they need you to be
fearless
and to take on the tasks of ahead with
some courage
do however avoid litigation
and if you can't avoid it win
all right personal characteristics so
those are the kind of the two
points of
highest impact
in dealing with
in managing situations that will lead to
trust now the the three that i would
like to mention that are personal
characteristics that will increase
people's willingness to trust you the
first is to laugh at yourself
um
people will like you more if you can
laugh at yourself
and poke fun at your mistakes
i promise you
they will be laughing at you
so you might as well beat them to the
punch
i've got some great examples there but
we're out of time so you're gonna
i am so lucky to miss telling you that
um
the second
thing is to be open and to look at
alternatives
and the best way i like to think about
this is as a pilot you're flying over
the terrain that you're leading think
about flying at strafing level which is
right at the at the ground
and flying at 30 000 feet where you
really are seeing and you have to as a
leader be open to both of those you have
to triangulate on problems and i've got
also a
great personal story there that i'll
skip over
um
but i'll tell i'll tell one of my class
s 355 class
when i run out of stuff there
finally
be optimistic
and i know that that may sound
kind of like a
you know there's nothing to be
optimistic about necessarily in the
world
choose to be optimistic good stuff
happens bad stuff happens choose to be
optimistic people are more likely
to trust you see discouragement is
temporary and i will tell you a lesson
here because it was so powerfully
learned
i just moved out to the west coast i was
dealing with the departure of our most
successful operation
we had just had our little son had been
attacked by a dog
and had to have plastic surgery
i was in the midst of negotiations
with a very
difficult
partner very difficult situation
i just gotten word that my father had
passed away
we were living in a house that was under
construction our sixth child had been
born
and i got home and the only way we could
wash dishes was in the bathtub it was
the only place to wash dishes and i
remember getting home that night and
saying well can i help you with the
dishes
and my wife's saying well actually the
bathtub is plugged up
could you take them out on the lawn and
wash them off with a garden hose
and i thought you know is there anything
else you know and then i started
thinking you know
i still have my friends i still have my
family i have my faith i have my freedom
i have
what i've learned i have my experiences
nothing that's really important is at
peril
so i am going to be optimistic and i've
remembered that several times and i want
to
quote
winston churchill
who went to a prep school
in the darkest days of world war ii
and met with the
young students there and he warned them
not to speak of darker days
but of sterner ones
these are not dark days these are great
days the greatest days our country has
ever lived
we must all thank god we've been allowed
each of us according to our stations to
play a part in making these days
memorable
in history
well
i've done a good job of
filling up the time so there's no time
for questions so let me just finish uh
then by saying that
i am really
um
so confident that you all
will make this
world a much better place
for being here and that through your
leadership
and your good hearts you will make a
difference i'm also confident that
you'll find happiness
through becoming the person that you can
be and want to be and discovering who
that person is through finding and
providing
love and care in life and finding a work
to which you'll devote your very
considerable talents uh and energies
thank you